- And it was a frightening
time, which helps account
for the Alien and Sedition
Acts, which, of course,
have discredited the Federalists.
I actually think this was
the most frightening moment
in our history with the
second most frightening
may have been in early 1942 when we feared
a Japanese invasion.
And you know what we did
interning hundred of thousands
of Japanese, many of them
citizens of the United States,
not just aliens but citizens.
We were frightened of an invasion.
Now, the invasion didn't occur,
and therefore we feel terribly guilty
and embarrassed by that.
The same thing happened.
The French did not actually invade,
and therefore, it makes
the Federalists' fears
seem wrongheaded, but they
didn't know the future.